in the last couple of videos I had
started a cupcake factory and I was the
richest guy in town and I was doing so
well that it attracted competition and
then Imran came in and he started his
own cupcake factory and he took all of
my business and he ended up you know
charging $2 90 and I think the number I
used in the last video you know he sold
like 500,000 cupcakes and he had this
great return on asset I think it was 20%
something he took away all my business
and I got decimated I think my cupcakes
I was originally charging something like
$3 and my cupcakes I only started
selling 250,000 of them and then my
return on asset essentially went to zero
I was kind of breakeven and at the end
of the last video you know not being a
great business man I said oh well
actually let me just raise prices
because you know I have this set number
of customers and they like the way I
operate the cash register a little bit
or maybe they live a little bit closer
to my cupcake factory or my bakery or
whatever you want to call it and so I
actually raise prices to cut out a
little bit of a profit but actually to
end up by doing that I do lose a couple
of these people because they are willing
to walk a little bit further for a
cupcake but I get an OK return but this
is kind of maximizing it and then over
time more and more people realize that
in Ron's charging so much less for
cupcakes so actually my revenue stream
starts to decline because fewer and
fewer people show up and say you know
what this really isn't a sustainable
situation and Ron came here hears this
he has his own what was it he was he was
selling 500 thousand right he's getting
this great return acid I'm getting this
crummy return on asset I'm only making
40,000 a year he's making $300,000 a
year
I need to get back at him so what I do
is I say well you know let me lower the
price and besides taking some of his
business there will actually be some
incremental more people in the town who
will actually start buying it so it's
not a zero-sum game a zero-sum game
means that if I win someone else is
losing by that amount if I lower prices
I'll take some business from Enron but
there'll also be people who were
probably eating something more
nutritious than cupcakes who might now
eat cupcakes to get their daily
requirements of sugar and trans fats and
in the case of my cupcakes nicotine so
let's say I cut prices below Imran
because I
increased price strategy was kind of
silly so I lower my prices to two
dollars and seventy and at $2 seventy
I'm able to sell I don't know 400
thousand cupcakes and I took some
business from memmer I mean I'm not like
a lot cheaper than him but I'm a good
bit cheaper so let's say I took some
business so he's only selling 400,000
cupcakes and now the aggregate cupcake
I'm actually not let's ignore this for a
little bit because now in this reality
I'm getting a 15% return on my asset in
Ron's getting a 7% return on asset let's
say there's a third party Vikram and he
just has a love for making cupcakes and
he says well you know what if I could
spend my life making cupcakes and even
if I just get a 7% return that's a
pretty good living and you know a 15%
return would be great so he also enters
the market and he's kind of a smaller
operator he didn't have quite as much so
he puts $500,000 into it he has 400,000
cupcake per year capacity since as a
smaller factor it's a little less
efficient so it cost him a little bit
more to produce a cupcake and he comes
in and he says you know I just want my
joy in life isn't so much well you know
he obviously has to pay his bills and he
likes to be rich but he says he just
drives joy from seeing people eat
cupcakes so he undercuts everybody and
in doing so he just operates at full
capacity he just takes he operates it
400,000 he operates at full capacity
while and then he takes business from
these guys and then he takes business
from me as well and then what's the
state of affairs in our city now so my
return on asset is 7% Imran is
essentially at breakeven he's making no
money
and then Vikram is making a 12% return
on asset because essentially he undercut
everyone was able to take all of the
volume and if you look at the city as a
whole
that's the aggregate capacity right here
this is the second worksheet in that in
that I'm actually let me tell you where
it is again just so you know if you
didn't watch the last videos
khanacademy.org /downloads flash
cupcakes dot XLS but anyway Vikram had
entered the market and now I calculated
here aggregate mass aggregate capacity
this is the total number of cupcakes all
of the factories in the market can
produce this is the aggregate demand so
1.1 million cupcakes you're getting sold
a year and this is the average return on
asset right but in this situation what
what continues to happen right I have
all of this extra capacity I have you
know only 32% of my capacities being
utilized and obviously you know right
now kind of you can say the market price
for cupcakes is well above the marginal
cost of producing a cupcake and in Ron
sitting there with this huge amount of
capacity and he's maybe he's with the
richest guy because he has huge
inheritance from from Grandma and and so
he says you know this is silly I'm
making I'm the biggest guy in town I'm
the most efficient guy in town I have
all the capacity I'm the richest guy in
town and I'm making the worst returns on
assets so what he says is you know what
I'm just going to undercut everybody I'm
going to charge one dollar seventy per
cupcake and a dollar seventy per cupcake
all of a sudden there's a whole new
market for people who want to buy e two
cupcakes there's a lot of people who
might have been eating you know Twinkies
and other things that maybe they could
get at a dollar eighty per Twinkie and
now cupcakes are the desired source of
food so you know obviously aggregate
demand is going to go up and let's say
he just he just sells out he just goes
he sells two million cupcakes a year and
so he makes a huge return and he just
kind of you know he kills our business
so I'm just taking huge losses and
Vikram is taking huge losses right we'd
you know we're selling none so he's like
oh you know what we have to match his
prices so I sell I sell it at a dollar
seventy and Vikram says at a dollar
seventy and we said at a dollar seventy
people are willing to eat two million
cupcakes in a year so let's say at a
dollar seventy it's it's split evenly
between the well Vikram can only produce
400,000 cupcakes so let's say he sells
let's say he sells 400,000
and then the remainder is split between
the other two so let's see 800,000 and
800,000 and as you can see here I mean
there's a general trend is is that you
know as people have extra capacity
there's this there's almost this
incentive to lower your price relative
to the other person because if you're
not using your capacity then that's a
that's a cupcake that's not being
permits not being made that otherwise
could have been made and your cost of
producing that incremental cupcake is
only you know is a lot lower so it's
like well you know if I just as long as
I charge something more than that I'm
going to make money that I otherwise
wouldn't have made but when you do that
you're actually lowering the market
price and then all of the parties keep
wanting to do that and that's why
competition really is good for customers
and that's why I'm monopoly is bad if
you were a monopoly if Sal's cupcakes
was the only guy in town he could just
keep his prices high and even if his
utilisation went down there would be no
incentive for him to lower prices but in
this reality with competition there's
this huge incentive that when you have
extra capacity when you have extra
capacity especially if you have a lot of
extra capacity there's this huge
incentive to lower prices so that you
can utilize that capacity and likewise
if you're at if you're running near full
capacity there's a huge incentive to
raise prices because if you're at full
capacity and we saw that in the last
video then when it was just me I went to
full capacity now I was able to raise
prices because it all that extra money
just goes to me but you can see that you
know there's a kind of a couple of key
learning points in this set of videos is
that when you have huge returns as I you
know Sal's cupcakes had in this video or
in this worksheet over here when you
have huge returns it attracts
competition the competition attracts
capacity right we went from aggregate
capacity from 1 million with my original
factory to now 3.4 million and then when
you have that extra capacity
everyone's incentive is really to lower
prices so that they can try to grab some
of that utilization and the only way
that you can avoid this is if you know
Sal Imran and Vikram were to meet in a
room and say hey guys what we're doing
is silly why don't we just all agree on
a price and you might say that's a good
business move and if you actually did it
you would end up in jail well hope
so you'd be in jail if you had good
regulators because that's called
collusion you would be forming a cartel
you'd before having a group that is
trying to control prices so in a truly
competitive environment we're not
allowed to communicate and we're not
allowed to tell each other hey why don't
we just set prices at X well actually
just kind of what we we're always have
to be competing with each other and
lowering our prices but the general
theme here is when you're at high
utilization and this is you know the
whole reason why I'm even entering into
this whole spreadsheet and all that is
to talk about inflation in general but
in general prices will go up when you
have high utilization right if all of us
were running at 100% utilization let's
actually let's let's do that scenario
let's say for whatever reason everyone
is able to get cheap loans and they take
home equity loans and they decide to use
all of that extra money that is coming
from their home ATM to buy cupcakes so
aggregate demand goes up huge and all of
the cupcakes in the market gets sold out
right so I'm selling a million cupcakes
per year Imran is selling two million
cupcakes per year and then Vikram is
selling foreign so we're all tapped out
we're at 100% capacity utilization and
then the return on assets are pretty
good but we all is you know we all as a
group say wow you know if I'm already
sold out why don't I just raise prices
because you know it's not going to
affect a man so much people want
cupcakes so badly so I could raise
prices to $2 that improves my return on
asset Iran's no dummy so he does the
same thing he raises price to $2 and
let's say people are getting so much
money from their home equity loans that
they're still willing to buy the
cupcakes from us and Vikram does the
same to dollars and so everyone's return
on asset improves even more and you
could even argue that it would attract
competition but I think three players is
good enough and let's say it just keeps
happening and we you know I decided I
realize that I can raise my prices all
the way to $3 without it affecting
without affecting my utilization without
any impact on demand $3 let's say it has
a slight impact on utilization so you
know I'm selling 950 thousand cupcakes a
year he's selling I don't know one point
eight million cupcakes in a year and
let's say Vikram is selling
380,000 cupcakes in a year but in
general if you look at kind of the
returns in the industry in this
situation by raising our prices we're
getting better and better returns right
more money's coming to the bottom line
so as long as we have a pretty high
utilization and people debate on what
kind of what is the level of utilization
a lot of industries where it makes sense
to raise prices but when you're at a
relatively high utilization it really
pays to to increase your price hurdle
and on the other side of the coin when
you have a low utilization of your asset
even though it might not be completely
well it is rational if you're a
competitor but when you have very low
utilization you essentially want to
lower your prices so that you can
utilize your factory more and you can
play around with this and just think
about some scenarios yourself and that's
the real big takeaway I wanted you to
get at is that high utilization of
anything of our aggregate capacity
prices will increase lower utilization
prices will decrease and actually I'll
say two things high utilization high
utilization will revert will will allow
you to raise prices and it will and when
you raise price you'll get a better
return on your asset and then the other
side effect is when you have that high
return on asset you'll also have more
investment going on to build more
capacity right so aggregate capacity
will go on so those are the two side
effects of high utilization you have
prices increasing and then you have more
capacity or more investment coming on
low utilization you have kind of the
opposite situation no incentive for
someone to add a factory like we did in
these situations and there's every
incentive for every player in the market
to lower prices because they just want
to use their factories otherwise their
factories just go being unutilized
anyway I think I've said the same thing
five times in different ways but I think
that's your point I'll return to the
drawing board literally in the next
video and we can proceed with our
discussion of inflation and deflation